[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
this here brother and sisters is a story
that was shared by Hamza chimeev one of
our brothers in Islam who is involved in
MMA
um and this is what he had to say so he
saw I think some kind of an oppression
done to the Palestinians and you need to
understand guys whoever it is any human
being for that matter there have been
non-muslims who have traveled there and
have lost their lives while fighting for
the cause of the Palestinians so here
you can very see uh clay bomb says he
says you are just guests of Palestine
respect them for giving you Asylum which
is true one day you will be expelled
from Palestine inshallah inshallah I
said inshallah by the way give me the
strongest man from Israel I will break
him
um there's a lot of facts in that
statement but that post was taken down
it can be from his PR team maybe
Instagram for that matter we don't know
but what is important brother and
sisters is that like the prophet
Muhammad sallam said if you see evil try
to stop it with your hands try to do
something about it if you cannot do that
speak out against it and if you cannot
do that at least hate it in your heart
we can see with our brother Hamza over
here that he not only he's in his heart
he has spoken verbally against it and
he's ready to smash some Israelis if he
can with his hands so as you can see
brother sister subhanallah he is
fulfilling three of those inshallah and
merely accepted from him and it's very
important for us to understand the pride
of the Palestinians or the ummah
whatever it is for that matter anyone
that's oppressed brothers and sisters uh
subhanallah is very very important in
Islam though it's not just a matter of
Muslims but anyone Christian Jew whoever
he is whoever it is you see someone
being oppressed you come and talk about
him myself personally I was in Stamford
Hill about a couple of years ago and
there was a rabbi who was walking about
his business and a individual came and
attacked him I've done a video about it
I raised awareness why because he's an
innocent person why should he be
attacked so do not forget Roman sisters
what's going on in Morocco the
earthquake was hit there and subhanallah
I've even heard that Ronaldo who owns a
hotel building there has opened these
doors to help the ummah brothers and
sisters if non-muslims like people like
Ronaldo with a kind Hotmail like into
Islam is opening their hearts
subhanallah and their businesses to help
the poor I am working with one ummah and
I've got Brothers on the ground
subhanallah who are there as we speak
now who are inshallah helping our
brothers and sisters who have been
struck and stricken by the earthquake so
please brother and sisters whatever you
can give do not forget that one day that
could be you do not think that you're
living in your comfy houses and your
homes and this will never touch you the
punishment if Allah Wills would come and
will lie one day that might be us do not
forget the people of Syria who they used
to be the ones that used to give in
charity and zakar they used to say we
used to give help you know our brother
and sister in this country that country
and guess what the country when it went
to war the same thing happened to them
they were the ones that had to end up
receiving charity so please understand
that and brother Hamza may Allah bless
you inshallah for calling out these
oppressors may Allah deal with them and
indeed they are Asylum Seekers and
inshallah one day for their oppression
the zionists let's make it clear the
zionists will inshallah pay the price
subhanallah by leaving the lands that
they stole brother and sisters that's
all I'm going to say inshallah the link
for the Morocco donation is at the link
below please please inshallah help us
we're working with one ummah and let's
get those funds to those people who are
direly indeed inshallah and love for
your brother what you love for yourself